hello everyone and welcome to another
very nice game you uh suggested i cover
uh it's from the 38th open until
grombach tournament that was played uh
in well the past few days and it's a
game between uh russian grand master
viacheslavikonikov and um uh aileen
reubers uh from netherlands could be
pronounced any other way i guess as uh
dutch names are always uh very very
difficult to pronounce uh but i'm going
with roy burst and she's only 15 years
old but she won the tournament so that's
very very impressive uh well probably
why you guys requested me to show it
and it's a really really intense game a
lot of things could have gone very very
differently and very wrong for for both
of them as you'll see but it's uh it's a
very enjoyable one so without further
ado let's check it out and see uh how
she managed to win this tournament so
here uh uh ikonikov opens with d4 we
have d five c for c6 knight to f3 and
knight to f6 we have the slob defense on
the board knight to c3 and e6 uh going
for the semi-slab defense and now
usually e3 is pretty standard here but
white goes for bishop queen to b3
uh now putting pressure on more a little
bit more pressure on d5 also putting
pressure on b7 so black cannot develop
this bishop for the moment here we have
d captures on c4 uh very principle
decision as you are uh trying to make
white pay for developing the queen to
early so white has to waste some tempe
here queen captures on c4 and now b5
further harassing the queen queen d3 and
now a6 um so
defending that b5 pawn so you can
advance this pawn to c5
and attack white's center so here bishop
to g5 nicely developing and now usually
uh just c5 is played here but she first
develops the light square bishop we have
bishop to b7 and now white grabs the
center with e4 we have h6 bishop to h4
uh and only now c5 um
attacking white strong center and the
position has been reached even this year
he was reached in the serbian team
championship between alexander indigen
uh and hans mocheniman where d5 was
played and black was able to win this
game but here we have e5 and it is now
as of movie 11 that we have a completely
new game uh and let's see how how e5 is
different from d5 well for one uh the
knight cannot move if the knight moves
you lose the queen so that is uh she
just blundering the knight uh well not
really uh g5 now if uh pawn captures
knight we have pawn captures bishop uh
so white just goes knight captures and
g5 captures captures and now you've
temporarily sacrificed a piece but
you're gonna win the knight back so it's
not a problem uh here we have c4
further attacking the queen here queen
to d2 and now knight b to d7 you can't
save the knight so you might as well
continue development uh we have e
captures on f6 with
a white wins the piece back and now we
have b4 uh you could play many many
different moves here like you could
capture on f6 but that looks a little
bit weird uh and it doesn't seem like
black is all that interested in winning
a pawn back so here b4 attacking the
knight and already white is under a lot
of pressure now black king is also in
the center of the board but the white
king is a bit more open and here you
have to play very very precise moves and
knight to d1 seems to be the move you
have to play here but here knight to a4
was played
and this gives um a black uh well just
many ways to continue this one of them
being the most straightforward one and
that is c3 so the queen is attacked and
you can't really capture here whoops
sorry about that if you capture on c3
queen to a5 and what what do you do here
you're attacking the knight you can't
really defend the knight if you move the
knight then you lose control of c three
b captures uh big captures and c3 will
create a very strong pass pawn and it's
just a terrible terrible position for
white so instead after c3 we have queen
to e3 and now knight to b6 offering a
trade of knights here which white should
definitely accept but instead white
plays b3 here
and this is now uh well maybe a little
bit too much giving black a pass pawn on
c3 already but okay knight captures on
a4 b captures and queen to b6 now
developing the queen also might be
preparing queen side castles so bishop
to f4 as the d4 pawn will come under
attack so you want to play bishop to e5
to defend both of your pawns and now we
have rook to d8 black could also castle
queen side here but she goes for rook to
d8
and now we have bishop to e5 we have to
defend our d4 pawn b3 now with the idea
of well just further activating this
queen so a captures on b3 queen captures
on b3 and now bishop to d3
asking what do you want to do here and
it's a really really interesting
position where again
many things are possible because it's
such an open position both kings are in
the center of the board both both
players have the bishop pair the queens
are on the board it's it's a very very
cool position uh in the game bishop to
h6 was played uh but uh just to give you
an example of what the engine thinks is
best bishop captures on g2
runs into rook to g1 and now rook to h3
this is seemingly best for black but
again it doesn't give black all that
much queen to e2 now you have to find c2
with the crazy
idea that if queen captures on c2 just
go back queen to b7 and defend your
bishop here with black having a very
comfortable game and of course if white
captures with the bishop well then just
bishop to b for check and the white is
dead lost so uh there are some ideas
with bishop captures on g2 but okay
bishop to h6 first attacks the queen now
comes queen to g3 you could also block
with f4 naviation decides to play queen
to g3 and now uh what do you play here
well here elin played queen king to d7
and it's such a
such a tricky move to to face over the
board especially if the time on the
clock was low as uh and as i understand
it it was uh by the way i forgot to
mention in the description there will be
a link to a chess.com article by peter
dodgers where he talks a little bit more
about the tournament and uh what what
happened there and a little bit more
about a lean uh so do check that out as
well uh so just uh again to give you an
example if bishop the d to check and
this seems like a move you you really
want to play we're going to play king
the e2 and now how do you continue this
well it's very very hard to to find the
move here for black unless you find
bishop to f4
that's what you what you kind of have to
play and now there are some very very
impressive ideas here with queen b2
check uh and not a lot of thing to do
here uh for example if you play queen
captures on f4 if you grab the bishop we
just play queen b to check and well it's
it's just a very very bad position for
white so what you would have to do here
after bishop to f4 is play rook to b1
and here we would have a queen trade but
this way captures captures we're going
to play bishop captures on g3 h captures
bishop captures here and now bishop
captures an a6 and we finish this
position with white being up a pawn and
it's a past a pawn
so this will be definitely
advantageous for white so although it
seems like the the absolute best move it
doesn't give black all that much so here
she played king to d7 which leaves you a
lot of options you could hide the king
on the queen side you could bring this
rook into the attack here
so it's a it's a very tricky move and
definitely a move you don't want to see
in time trouble so here we have rook the
b1
now you have to be careful otherwise
you're going to lose the bishop so queen
d5 defends the bishop and now f3 so you
no longer have to worry about the weak
g2 pawn and only now bishop to d2 with
check we have king f2 now comes the
bishop the c6
so you don't have the bishop here as a
target but bishop c6 is uh
well is is a move that gives white a
winning advantage unfortunately for a
lean here you want to play rook h the g8
or rook d the g8 and harass that queen
but still the position is better for
white
however after bishop to c6 the position
is completely winning for white but
again you have to play it very precisely
so queen to g7 of course we go after the
f7 pawn luckily the the king moved so we
can block with the rook and then now a
brilliant move by the atchiso rather the
only winning move in the position that
is a rook to b8
now the point being if rook captures on
b8 uh well we're just going to capture
on f7 and after king to d8 we're just
going to check mate the black king check
here and the queen to e7 will be
checkmate so how can uh elaine get out
of this uh you can capture the rook but
also if you just allow rook captures an
f8 you're going to be down the rook here
she played queen to a2 and this is a
very very tricky idea saying that if you
capture my rook here
or you know with
with the other rook i'm just going to
play bishop to e3 with check and now
after the king moves and you don't
really have all that many squares queen
to f2 with czech king g4 and now even
rook to h4 with checkmate so there are
many such ideas in the position so
instead after this queen to a two move
king the g3 was played
and now how do you continue bishop to e3
again very tricky uh as you you again
might get checkmated kenji for rook to
h4 so rook to f1 the only winning move
for white so uh iconic of playing a very
very
uh you know uh the only moves basically
here and now queen to a3 retraining and
defending that rook here and now iconic
have played everything perfectly and now
he just has to uh you know finish the
game but it's not all that clear how do
you how do you finish the game yes you
are
you are you know winning and
uh the engine screams that you are
winning but in time trouble it's hard to
find a winning move here just to give
you an example of how difficult the
position is uh bishop captures an a6 is
the engine's all-time favorite move and
of course the the engines uh you know
they love their pawns uh but uh in in
this kind of a crazy position who would
play bishop captures an a6 so one of the
moves that actually wins the position is
bishop to g6
but it's still not all that easy in time
travel because you have to give up your
queen temporarily for example rook h to
g8 bishop captures on f7 now and after
rook captures f captures and g7
attacking the rook and okay now now it's
clear that white will win the game
uh for example rook captures on b8 we're
going to play bishop captures and we get
another queen into the game however
that's uh it seems that it's easier said
than done in the game economic of tried
queen captures an h8 seems like it's uh
similar and that white will be able to
will
get to this pawn uh try to advance this
pawn also he will try to advance this
pawn
but it's not as clear so rook captures
on h8 rook captures an h8 and now the
position is pretty much winning uh for
for konikov unless uh roibers plays one
move that gives her the advantage so
feel free to pause the video and try to
find this uh elusive idea in this
difficult position while i give you a
couple of seconds
[Music]
so for those of you who were able to do
it congratulations on spotting this
incredible idea and for those of you who
just want to enjoy the show it is bishop
captures on d4 that's the movie konig of
missed when he played this uh
uh well uh giving up the queen for two
rooks idea uh and now the problem is if
the bishop is captured well then queen
to d6 check and after king h3 we pick up
the bishop on d4 attack this bishop
attack the f6 pawn and after let's say
rook to d1 we can just pick up the pawn
we don't even care because there are no
good discoveries on the king for example
bishop captures an a6 we're going to
play king e7 and now black is much much
better here or rather black is winning
here as uh well the the the coordination
between white's pieces isn't all that
impressive and the white king is kind of
boxed in here
on h3 uh so that's one problem uh
another one is well you just can't
capture on the for bishop to f4 was
played
but not just the bishop captures on f6
so just grabbing two of these very very
important pawns just like that uh really
uh will make it troublesome for white to
uh to win this so rook the h7 now king
e7 defending the pawn bishop to g6 now
but now bishop to e8 so everything is
nicely defended we have rook to b1 going
for rook to b7 check
but now e5 are starting to advance the
pawn also asking what do you do with the
bishop here so bishop c1 attacking the
queen the bishop will also be needed in
guarding the c1 square as it's the
queening square for the c pawn queen
back to d6 and now uh rook to b7 should
be played here but uh economical first
place bishop captures on f7 uh he will
win the piece back of course but uh it's
just uh way way worse than rook to b7 so
here bishop captures was played rook to
b7 check king to e6 and now rook b
captures on f7
but now uh
white will have some problems here queen
to d1 attacking the bishop here bishop
to a3 and now comes queen captures on a4
and now okay you're threatening to win
the bishop here uh so bishop back to c1
but this bishop to c1 is actually a
mistake rook the b7
was the only way to continue this with
white it it's it's a very scary position
but at least it gives you some fighting
chance uh for example if you capture the
bishop then rook b6 check and black
might be uh in some trouble for example
uh if you go king to f5 we're gonna play
rook to f7 and now well it's actually
black who has to uh be worried about
getting checkmated uh but okay it's
still it's still a dead draw if both
sides play correctly so here bishop the
c1 was played but now queen the a1
attacking the bishop bishop to e3 and
now queen to e1 with check so now you
either lose the bishop or you have to
give up control of the queening square
so bishop f2 now comes queen to d2 and
now rook the c7 you can play some like
rook h6 to go after the bishop because
the queen here guards the h6 square
also one of the problems for white so
rook the c7 was played but now c2
preparing c1 queen here rook the c6
check was played king to f5 and it was
in this position on mu 47 that we
actually konikov resigned in the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
there's no way to increase any pressure
you can give one small check but after
king to g6 there are no more moves you
can play whatever you play c1 queen is
coming
and other than that there there really
isn't anything he can play
uh so really really impressive game uh
it was uh it was hard fought by both of
them and then when the game reached time
trouble uh then well uh he who had or
she who had the strongest nerves in this
case uh wins the game uh there's also a
nice photo of this from the article by
peter dodgers uh that you can check out
here's a photo of them playing in the
final round there you can see the the
starting position the queen is already
on d3
and also here are the final standings
here you can see that she won the
tournament with six and a half points
ahead of everyone else uh whereas uh
ikonico who who is uh in ninth place uh
finished on five points if he had won
the final game he would tie for first
with uh oliver stork and um
i cannot pronounce this but we're gonna
go with kaufman
uh but yeah you can see that uh elena
roberts uh is
untitled she does not have a title and
she left some very very strong title
players behind a couple of feeding
masters an international master and a
grand master so very very nicely done a
wonderful wonderfully fought the game
and we'll see what uh what what she has
in store for the chess world uh well
after after this tournament this she's
only 15 already rated almost 2400 so
we'll see what happens we'll be
following the progress uh so yeah that's
the game thank you guys for suggesting
it hope you enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank jonathan maesta david
uh robert starlman uh benjamin bryant
and ryan urban for your contribution to
my channel thank you a lot to really
appreciate it uh as usual you can check
to my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day